divers have pulled more boys out of a
flooded cave in northern Thailand as the
world watches video from the scene
appears to show the first of four new
rescues being taken from the scene by
helicopter rescuers are now done with
the second stage of a dangerous mission
to save a soccer team trapped for more
than two weeks
the first evacuate this morning was the
fifth boy to be rescued four other boys
were brought out of the cave over the
weekend when tracey's at the scene
outside chiang rai thailand been good
morning good morning the second phase of
this dangerous rescue mission was a
success they have rescued four more of
these boys there are five now remaining
in the cave and they hope to rescue them
tomorrow inside the cave workers have
been drilling holes into the rock the
rescue teams can more easily navigate
the dark and wet cavern their efforts
are paying off this video shows the
first group of boys just moments after
being rescued from the cave within two
minutes they were on helicopters and
flown to a hospital in chiang rai where
beds were lined up at the front door so
far Thai officials say the elaborate
rescue operation has gone better and
faster than they expected a source tells
CBS News they have added five more
people to the international team of 18
expert divers in hopes they can rescue
the remaining boys in their coach in a
shorter period of time
here's how this dangerous rescue mission
works each of the boys is wearing a dive
mask as they enter the murky water the
children can barely see anything in
front of them they are led by a diver
who is carrying their oxygen tank and
guided by a rope another diver follows
them from behind the entire journey
covers about two and a half miles
through both deep water and steep climbs
the biggest concern is a pinch point in
the cave that is just 15 inches across
in that area the boys have to separate
from the divers in order to fit through
and reach a small patch of dry land
before going back down into the water
the Thai government says each boy
ranging in age from 11 to 16 and their
25 year old coach was assessed and
cleared by a doctor that the boys were
made fully aware of the rest
you plan agreeing to face whatever it
took to get out of the case now
officials here say it could take 24 to
48 hours to rescue everyone in that cave
they are racing time and they are racing
the weather they want to make sure that
they get everybody out before any sort
of heavy rains come and potentially
flood that cave again which would make
this rescue effort much more challenging
then how do they decide which boys go
out first well the local governor here
who is acting as the head of this rescue
mission he says that they're actually
taking the strongest boys out first that
may seem counterintuitive but the
reasoning for that is likely that they
want to get they want the boys who have
the best chance of surviving getting
through this rescue mission first they
also want to give these divers the
chance to go through this several times
before they would get to the boys that
are perhaps weaker and would be more
risky Nora well those successful rescues
have kept morale up and I know that's
very important then thank you so much